وصلنا الى هذا المكان المدمر بالكامل خلال
ليله عصيبه عاشتها هذه المنطقه غارات
عنيفه لكن لم نتوقع ان هذا المكان اصبح
بهذه الدرجه من الدمار عشرات مئات المنازل
البنايات السكنيه في هذه المنطقه الراقيه
والتي تتضمن مئات المنازل يقن عشرات
الالاف من المواطنين الفلسطينيين
هي جزء من منطقه تل الهواء على الاطراف
الواقعه بين تل الهواء والرمال الجنوبي
وكما تشاهدون بنظره عامه ليست بنايه ولا
اثنتان ولا ع ولا 20 بنايه لكن نستطيع
القول ان هذا المربع بالكامل تم تدميره
بشكل او باخر حتى المنازل التي لم تدمر
بالكامل اصبحت خارج الخدمه ولا يمكن
استخدامها على العكس هي تشكل اخطارا كبيره
على اي انسان يتحرك او ياتي الى هذا
المكان وكما تلاحظون لا فائده هو بحاجه
الى ربما معدات ثقيله وكبيره وقويه تستطيع
التعامل مع هذه الكومه الضخمه من الركام
والحطام وبالتالي هذا ربما يدخلنا الى
الحاجه او الحاله الانسانيه
التي يعيشها قطاع غزه سواء قطاع الدفاع
المدني او رجال الاسعاف وحتى المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين يعيشون في
هذه اللحظات اصعب لحظه ربما مرت عليهم بما
في ذلك في الحروب السابقه بالتاكيد هذا
المكان كان يسكنه كما قلنا عشرات الالاف
هناك نداءات استغاثه كثيره جهت من القطاع
الصحي ومن رجال الدفاع المدني يتحدثون عن
كارثه وشيكه ربما تحل بقطاع غزه وحالات
وفاه بالالاف ان لم يصار الى ادخال
مساعدات للدفاع المدني وللقطاع الصحي من
خلال المعابر وذلك يتطلب فتح المعابر
بطبيعه الحال هذا هو واقع الحال حقيقه في
قطاع غزه وطالما ان اصوات الطائرات في ماء
وان هذه الحرب مستمره فهذا بالتاكيد يعني
ان هذه الصوره سوف تتكرر في اماكن كثيره
وان اعداد الشهداء في تزايد والحاله
الانسانيه تتعمق اكثر فاكثر وائل الدحدوح
الجزيره غزه فلسطين